Speaker 1: now.
On the other hand of things that might work
versus might not work, we now are seeing almost
daily installments in this confusing, bizarre
kind of aimless Republican civil war.
But today we have a new wrinkle.
The Republican Civil War has
Speaker 2: mostly been anti-Trump
Speaker 1: Republicans and pro-Trump Republicans
Speaker 2: fighting
Speaker 1: each other.
Like I said earlier this week, this is a civil
war we want to encourage.
It's a good thing for this to be going on
yesterday's episode.
We are Dan Crenshaw sort of offense writer
continuing to ride the fence and tread water
in the midst of the Civil War, saying, Well,
you know,
Speaker 2: the Freedom Caucus, people who
claim to be
Speaker 1: very pro-Trump, they didn't really
vote with Trump that much.
But people like Adam Kinzinger, who is seen
as anti-Trump, actually did vote for Trump.
Dan Crenshaw finding a way to ride the fence
that was yesterday.
Today, there's a new wrinkle.
And now it is just straight up Trumpist on
Trumpist Civil War.
Today we have Trumpian lawyer Lin Wood.
That's the same guy who briefly represented
Kyle Rittenhouse, and that's relevant.
Lin Wood is also the guy who was involved
in all sorts of 2020 election hirings.
That very same Lin Wood, Trumpian lawyer attacking
brutally Trumpian Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
Greene.
Even within the pro-Trump wing of the Republican
Party, there is now trouble in paradise, and
we should encourage this.
We should foment this.
Lin Wood is now accusing Marjorie Taylor Greene
of being under the influence of not not alcohol
of the devil.
After Kyle Rittenhouse claimed that Lin Wood
exploited him to make money.
Marjorie Taylor Greene tweet tweeted Quote
Lin should go to jail for what he did to Kyle.
I also fully blame him for why Georgia lost
our Senate seats.
He's from Georgia and we know him as a lifelong
Speaker 2: Democrat,
Speaker 1: not a Republican.
He grafted off of Trump and told people not
to vote on January 5th, saying their vote
would be stolen.
Lin Wood has now gone to the Daily Beast and
said he's thinking about suing Marjorie Taylor
Greene for defamation, suing Fox News propagandist
Tucker Carlson for defamation.
And he responded to this by saying quote,
I mean, from a biblical perspective, I think
she's under the influence of the devil because
people that follow Jesus Christ don't lie.
Marjorie Taylor Greene is a liar.
Speaker 2: Draw your own conclusions.
Speaker 1: Lynwood also told The Daily Beast
Greene was one of a number of deep state right
wing agents working to destroy his credibility.
Not a surprise there.
So when the lunatic extremists are fighting
each other, you know that all is not well
in their world, and I take two interest in
this one.
You already know this type of infighting can
only be
Speaker 2: good for the left.
It might not
Speaker 1: help the left, but it might, and
it certainly doesn't help the pro-Trump right.
If the left knows how to take advantage of
it.
But the more interesting piece is that this
is yet another data point that what unites
these people fundamentally is not actually
even support for Donald Trump.
There was one layer which was these are all
Republicans, and what unites them is conservative
values.
No, the pro-Trump Republicans
Speaker 2: had completely different values.
It's just Trump says, I'm a
Speaker 1: Republican, so they vote for Republicans
fight so that we were done with.
Well, maybe its support for Trump that actually
unites them.
Speaker 2: No.
Speaker 1: Lin Wood and Marjorie
Speaker 2: Taylor Greene both claim to
Speaker 1: love Trump.
They both support Trump.
They both say Trump is great.
Lin Wood claims Trump actually
Speaker 2: won the election.
Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor Greene claims Trump
actually won the election.
Lin Wood wants to take the election back,
however they can.
Marjorie Taylor Greene wants to take the election
back.
However, they can both believe Kyle Rittenhouse
acted in self-defense.
Speaker 2: You get the point.
Speaker 1: But as soon as there is anything
but
Speaker 2: complete deference to each other,
personally,
Speaker 1: they go to war.
The deep state, this the devil that you're
subject to this even the very Trumpism that
supposedly
Speaker 2: unites them is not
Speaker 1: enough to go beyond the personal.
For these folks, it's a complete and total
grift.
And the question is whether the left will
figure out how to take advantage of it and
actually win some elections.
Unfortunately, I remain very skeptical that
the Left actually knows what to do with this.
We'll talk about what the left could do with
this on an upcoming show.
If you have ideas, certainly let me know I
have some but always interested
in hearing from.
Hey, this
is really funny.